quem sou eu pra julgar
normalmente essa frase quando a gente
fala quem sou eu pra julgar é uma frase
que a gente fala uma expressão que a
gente fala antes do julgamento
a gente fala quem sou eu pra julgar
normalmente ou mais com o contraditório
que pareça a gente julga mas eu vou
estar aqui de um sentido um pouco culto
dessa frase que fica escondido
justamente pela pressa ao julgar quando
eu digo quem sou eu pra julgar
na verdade eu estou admitindo a minha
família ser falível estou admitindo a
minha humanidade e é nesse sentido que
eu quero pegar aqui é nesse sentido que
eu vou valores aqui trazendo justamente
esse sentido de falibilidade para quem
tem o ofício de julgar
nós juízes principalmente os juízes
criminais
quando eu falo em juízo principalmente
juízes criminais porque decidir de quem
essa tela é muito fácil muito tranqüilo
de que essa cadeira fácil julgar se uma
pessoa é culpada ou inocente algo muito
mais profundo dramático e difícil
quando a gente fala quem sou eu para
julgar esse exercício tem que ser diário
de verificar as nossas falhas e ver que
o nosso compromisso não é com a vingança
mas com um processo civilizatório
quando eu era pequeno tinha uns 12 anos
eu sou de brasília
lá em brasília tem pra quem conhece as
superquadras intenção conjunto dos 12 13
prédios em toda super quarta tem uma
banca de jornal que aqui você chama de
cigarreira sempre que meu pai e naquela
na banca de jornal
ele sempre me chamado lá talvez até para
incentivar a leitura ea pessoa da banca
de jornal ou o dono da banca de jornal
era extremamente mal educado
extremamente educado
naquela época não tinha computadores
então ele ficava anotando sempre
com números na caderneta zinha não
levantava a cabeça meu pai falava por
favor obrigado boa tarde bom dia sem
nunca haver uma resposta um dia na minha
sabedoria dos 12 anos eu falei pai deixa
de ser besta eu acho que eu não falei
besta porque existe um pouco mais de
respeito
falei pai ele nunca te respondi porque
você continua falando obrigado por favor
ele falou uma coisa te leva para a vida
e foi o filho eu não posso deixar que
ele me diga como eu devo agir
o estado quando para combater a
violência age de forma violenta está
deixando a viu a violência dizer como
ele deve agir e o compromisso já disse
aqui do judiciário não disseram não pode
ser direcionado pelo crime pelo delito
ele tem que ser direcionado pelo
compromisso com um processo
civilizatório
quando a gente fala em processo
civilizatório não tem como a gente
quando a gente fala a palavra processo
já está implícito nele o sentido de
tempo ea gente tem que questionar em que
tempo nós estamos vivendo essa revolução
tecnológica que parece vincular a
felicidade
a última versão de um hardware e o de um
software
a gente está confundindo tempo com
pressa e aí a cultura do descartável a
cultura da rapidez da instantaneidade e
da coisificação das pessoas
outro dia estava até pensando poxa no
meu tempo quando eu saía com a menina
era uma namorada namorada porque tá no
coração namorada hoje a gente pega sem
um falso pudor aqui a gente perde o
objeto
a gente tem que entender sem tempo para
tentar resgatar algo diferente nele um
tempo mais humanizado
lembro que esse tempo acelerado
trazido para quem é aqui do direito algo
terrível para quem depois a operar com
direito
o fetiche o texto legal achar que a lei
é tudo ela responde a tudo ela sabe
da vida e não sabe é também a
cultura dos especialistas do
despedaçamento do conhecimento
essas duas coisas simplificam algo que é
complexo que a vida nos rejeito a
complexidade da vida talvez pela pressa
pela preocupação de número e não da
qualidade de julgar pessoas quando eu
resgato o patos quandú finto que o tempo
pode ser reflexão e não só pressa
resgato algo que os gregos antigamente
chamado de patos que a emoção a
responsabilidade com o outro e isso faz
toda a diferença
o aspecto do fetiche é o texto legal é
profundamente danoso
se o jogador não se preocupar com isso
lembro de um caso de uma estudante
paranaense
eu assumi com o juiz federal no interior
de sergipe e itabaiana depois eu vim pra
cá cheguei aqui em 2007 sergipe não era
não era rota de tráfico internacional de
drogas
aqui é o primeiro caso que eu fui jogar
de tráfico internacional de um estudante
paranaense lado do paraná 19 anos pobre
tem que servir de mula para trazer estas
em maconha pra cá da holanda pra cá ela
foi presa foi julgar é gozado que às
vezes a gente a a a15 um sentido comum
de achar que o juiz julga porque estudou
muita não o juiz tem que ter a percepção
da vida é a lei naquele tempo além de
drogas dizia o seguinte eu não posso
substituir a pena alternativa por para
quem pratica tráfico de
drogas o regime tem que ser inicialmente
fechado
não há possibilidade de seu regime
aquela moça me mostrou as circunstâncias
do julgamento que a lei estava errada
fiquei 15 dias sem dormir direito porque
não havia ainda naquela época nada na
doutrina dizendo que a lei é
inconstitucional
o afastamento do festivo do fetiche a
lei que me permitiu verificar como uma
das funções de juiz considerar aquela
lei inconstitucional aplicar sem a
substituição de pena eu condenei aquela
moça a dois anos e seis meses de
prestação de serviço comunitário
entidade serviço público de recuperação
de dependentes químicos obriguei também
na sentença o retorno aos estudos
comprovando assiduidade aproveitamento e
botei naquela época a pena de multa
poderia ser parcelada pela média que ela
tivesse nas duas últimas semanas rachas
da faculdade eu lembro que houve
repercussão na época porque tráfico de
drogas é algo que mexe muito com a
sociedade
me chamaram um debate acho que foi na
ufrn
achei que estava agradando no debate
jovens gostam de ouvir mudanças e aí uma
jornalista do andu antevisão aqui
primeiro liga a câmera que nem aqui nem
seja fica cego você fica desse tamanho
como eu tô me sentindo aqui e aí fala
assim posso fazer uma pergunta por fazer
pode né debate é pra isso e se ela
tivesse levando a droga para suas filhas
por cleiton ferrado
as minhas filhas são as coisas que eu
mais adoro no mundo sua vida brincando
a única resposta que me veio foi poxa eu
teria que mandar o processo para outros
juízes julgar se ele estivesse livre mas
posso devolver a pergunta falou pode
estar traficante por sua filha
só que gostaria que ela fosse julgado
o juiz com que visão de mundo
a possibilidade do patos da emoção do
resgate mil são permite a verificação de
algo muito maior do que o simples
direito
o pathos possibilita também o
afastamento de alguns símbolos errados
do resgate da ética e ética moderna hoje
nada mais é do que cuidar do outro
se preferirem solidariedade movimento
não me basta mais prass e ético me
solidarizar com o seu problema
eu tenho que agir para amenizar aquele
problema suavizar aquele problema
eu lembro de um julgamento de também de
2007 de 11 uma quadrilha de tem que
falar certo senão a gente leva à paulada
não é rápido de craques eu sei
craques é o que a gente acha que é racca
só que eles são especialistas em quebrar
em sistemas de segurança
eles quebravam sistemas descendo a caixa
econômica federal e depois sacavam
dinheiro dinheiro da conta de
correntistas
eles foram presos nessa operação da
polícia federal envolvendo o ceará aqui
em natal de são paulo foram presos 12
pessoas foram trazidas para cá quase
todos eram cartões erros que só
conseguiu um cartão para colocar a senha
e um era um menino de 18 para 19 anos
são paulo um gênio
ele é do programador lembra até gozada
acontece às coincidências na vida eu fiz
alguma besteira no dia da audiência meu
terminal a tela ficou o contrário ele é
chamado falou só quiseram com certo eu
falei pô solta cara e soltar ele
realmente não sei o que ele fez lá
deixou bonitinho
nesse julgamento a sala estava cheia
porque eram 12 réus mesmo número de
advogados e pessoas que vão assistir às
audiências porque é público
no final da audiência já sabia que a
soltá-los fez primeira vez que eu
coloquei como uma condição extra pelo
menos responder o processo em liberdade
a leitura de livros não é pra esses aí
fora vidas secas e olha vez de augusto
matraga e também para judiar dos hackers
outros craques que fazer um resumo a mão
sabe projudi ano
no final desse julgamento eu perguntei
pra ele eu não sou sadia com a pergunta
já tinha eu já sabia que a soltá lo e
falei porque eu tenho que te soltar para
isso programado
ele falou assim eu não vou mais fazer
não eo minha mãe ficou muito triste com
isso
aí ele parou e começou a chorar
profundamente na frente de todo mundo
ele falou assim meu pai que eu não vejo
há dez anos me mandou uma carta dizendo
que está profundamente decepcionado
comigo
soltei pediu o telefone do pai dele não
disse ele me deu
soltei fazer minhas coisas no final do
dia 7 6 8 horas lá na justiça federal
resolvi ligar pai dele me apresentei
como juiz que julgará o filho dele mas
falei que estava ligando como um pai e
não com juiz e que o filho dele
precisava da ajuda dele quando o tempo
vira um processo quando o tempo é vida
ele cria possibilidades 10 minutos do
meu tempo acabaram com dez anos de
silêncio e o pai dele participou da
recuperação desse menino
ele formou no ano passado 1
processamento de dados 4 pessoal não é
na razão que que estão os valores e na
emoção quando a gente recupera o pato a
gente tem experiência essencial que
leona que leonardo boff fala a
experiência essencial não é penso logo
existo é sinto logo existo essa foi a
primeira experiência a gente nunca pode
abrir mão
o equilíbrio entre as duas têm que ser
encontrados e quando a gente afasta
recupera a ética a gente também afasta
símbolos que não presta
as colunas dos tribunais a toga símbolos
que divinização uma atividade que é
meramente instrumental e transformadora
deve ser pelo menos voltar me permitir
colocar a falta de jeito porque
realmente eu nunca usei
usei uma vez de vocês vão saber agora
estou usando sertão
traz um formalismo é pra vocês
esse símbolo aqui que é expressar
superioridade igualdade perfeição ou
imperfeição
vocês gostariam de ser julgados por uma
pessoa superior e perfeita ou por alguém
perfeito é igual tem a ver gente com
tolerância filosófica com erro
quando eu sou intolerante com erro
quando eu acho que eu sou superior eu
sou melhor do que alguém a minha
sentença e sem nenhuma nenhum contexto
religioso é mera crucificação fez isso
pau é aquilo ali
quando eu tenho tolerância filosófica
com erro quando percebi igual a quem eu
estou julgando a sentença tem tudo tudo
para ser uma ressurreição fazer uma
transformação em símbolo não serve a
julgamento entre humanos por ser até ele
eu tenho aqui pra falar mais um juiz
criminal gente tem uma angústia de juiz
criminal que é o seguinte pessoas eu
jogo todo dia miséria brasileira
em alguns casos eu tenho a dúvida
sensação de interferência tardia
o estado chegou tarde pô eu assumi como
juiz federal há 13 anos no interior de
sergipe e itabaiana escolher um lugar de
interior porque eu queria conhecer a
realidade completou navalha comum mexer
com tudo e um dia primeiro dia como juiz
morrendo de medo em seguro pra caramba
estou na minha sala sozinho ligam da
secretaria bate telefone do tomate em
dez minutos começa a audiência no
tribunal tinha me falado que eu tinha
que usar a toga verde porque é da
justiça federal no qual automaticamente
peguei a toga botei ele foi pro banheiro
porque ela tinha um espelho assim pra só
para ver se estava arrumadinho
aí olhei nossa eu não gostei do que ouvi
falar a verdade eu me senti ridículo eu
comecei a questionar assim quem sou eu
pra julgar como pode uma pessoa que já é
o tanto na vida cheia de defeito com a
legitimidade que eu tenho para jogar
outras pessoas e eu fiquei pensando pô
será a legitimidade está porque foi
aprovado em um concurso público
a nomeação no diário oficial o juiz
mário azevedo jambo agora o juiz federal
a legitimidade está na no pretenso
conhecimento jurídico
não eu percebi naquele momento que a
legitimidade estava justamente nos meus
erros das minhas falhas na minha
humanidade a legitimidade para julgar
está na natureza humana
na certeza que réu e juiz na essência
são absolutamente iguais absolutamente
iguais ea partir daquele momento ali eu
vi sentir que jamais uma sentença pode
querer ser maior do que uma pessoa
jamais e que a justificativa moral de um
julgamento está no sentido mais profundo
da palavra humildade e terminando
pessoal eu gosto muito de uma música ana
carolina e tom zé une multiplicidade eu
não vou cantar pra não perder os amigos
mas é assim eu quero unir multiplicidade
onde cada homem sozinho a casa da
humanidade sejam os senhores todos nós
cada um de nós a casa da mãe da
humanidade muito obrigado ações